si escuchamos atentamente a nuestro
corazón nos daremos cuenta de que
produce sonidos y esos sonidos
normalmente se describen como tonta
tonta tonta y si te preguntas cómo se
escriben comúnmente se escribe como tú
y se repite una y otra y otra vez para
averiguar de dónde vienen esos sonidos
vamos a trabajar con el diagrama del
corazón que ya hemos estudiado solo que
esta vez exageramos las válvulas las
hicimos realmente grandes para poder
observarlas con claridad en esta imagen
usaremos esas válvulas para hablar de
dónde vienen esos sonidos así que
empecemos a etiquetar al corazón en la
parte de arriba llega la sangre a la
aurícula derecha pasa al ventrículo
derecho hace su viaje a los pulmones
regresa a la aurícula izquierda y
después al ventrículo izquierdo estas
son las cámaras
del corazón ahora no perdamos de vista
las válvulas ya que hablaremos de ellas
mientras la sangre pasa primero la
sangre se mueve de la aurícula derecha
de esta forma al ventrículo derecho al
mismo tiempo que la sangre se mueve de
la aurícula derecha al ventrículo
derecho la sangre también se mueve de la
aurícula izquierda al ventrículo
izquierdo y tal vez nos preguntemos cómo
es esto posible como puede ser que la
sangre esté en dos lugares al mismo
tiempo sin embargo recordemos que la
sangre se mueve constantemente a través
del corazón entonces en un ciclo
anterior tenemos algo de sangre que
viene de los pulmones y esta es la que
se vierte en el ventrículo izquierdo y
simultáneamente en un nuevo ciclo
tenemos la sangre que se vierte de la
aurícula derecha al ventrículo derecho
por lo tanto tenemos dos cámaras que
están llenas de sangre el ventrículo
derecho e izquierdo simultáneamente
ahora para que la sangre llegue a estos
ventrículos se abre las válvulas de
hecho vamos a etiquetar las aquí tenemos
a la válvula tricúspide y la etiqueta
haremos sólo con la letra t por acá
arriba tenemos la válvula pulmonar y
será p y del otro lado tenemos la
válvula mitral que separa la aurícula
izquierda del ventrículo izquierdo m y
por último tenemos a la válvula aórtica
estas son las cuatro válvulas del
corazón y ahora que la sangre está en
los ventrículos podemos ver que las
válvulas tricúspide y mitral están
abiertas bastante bien hasta aquí ahora
esta imagen tiene la válvula pulmonar
abierta pero es realmente el caso la
respuesta es no ya que la sangre está
bajando de la aurícula derecha al
ventrículo derecho
así que dibujemos una flecha en color
negro que represente el flujo en una
dirección incorrecta y pensemos que
parte de la sangre quiere ir en esta
dirección que no es la dirección en la
que debería entonces lo que pasará es
que estas dos válvulas con base en su
forma se cerrarán se cerrarán de esta
forma y no van a dejar pasar la sangre
esto es lo que pasa cuando esta válvula
se cierra y lo mismo pasa del otro lado
imagina que tenemos algo de sangre que
fluye de regreso por accidente es decir
que va en la dirección incorrecta
entonces estas válvulas se cerrarán
recordemos que las flechas blancas
representan un flujo correcto en la
sangre y las negras un flujo incorrecto
entonces estas válvulas también se
desterrarán
ahora podemos ver que las válvulas
pulmonar y aórtica están cerradas cuando
las válvulas mitral y tricúspide están
abiertas entonces qué pasa después de
eso bueno ahora los ventrículos se
llenan de sangre es cierto y digamos que
se contraen los ventrículos se contraen
y bombean tubo de la sangre a estas
arterias bueno en este punto estas
flechas se voltean es decir estas
flechas se vuelven blancas ya que la
dirección del flujo es la dirección que
queremos van a ir ahora en nuestra
dirección y también en esta otra
dirección para permitir eso claro está
mostraremos que estas válvulas se abren
ellas permiten que la sangre vaya en la
dirección en la que queremos que vaya
ahora la sangre fluye a través de estas
válvulas pero de manera similar que
antes podríamos tener sangre que vaya en
la dirección incorrecta por aquí y
sangre que vaya en la dirección
incorrecta por acá bueno pensemos que un
poco de sangre quiere ir en la dirección
contraria entonces lo que sucederá es
que estas válvulas se cerrarán ellas
dirán no no puedes ir hacia allá se van
a cerrar de esta forma y no permitirán
que la sangre pase en esa dirección así
que esto pasará en ambos lados en ambos
ventrículos básicamente que la sangre
fluya en la dirección contraria no está
permitido porque las válvulas lo impiden
y cuando las válvulas se cierran de
golpe por ejemplo justo ahora las
válvulas tricúspide y mitral se cierran
crean un ruido es decir cuando las
válvulas tricúspide en mitral se cierran
crean un ruido que llamamos tumor
este es nuestro primer ruido el primer
sonido de nuestro corazón de hecho
algunas personas no llaman esto lo
llaman primer ruido cardíaco oa veces lo
ponen como ese uno
si escuchamos ese 1 ya sabemos que
hablan del primer sonido del corazón
por su parte está es conocido como el
segundo ruido cardíaco y no nos
sorprende que como antes si el de arriba
es ese uno éste sea ese dos entonces
escuchamos ese uno cuando las válvulas
tricúspide y mitral se cierran muy bien
pero también sabemos que al mismo tiempo
las válvulas pulmonar y aórtica se abren
es decir mientras las otras válvulas se
cierran éstas se abren podemos suponer
esto aunque el ruido que escuchamos se
deba a que las válvulas se cierran ahora
que pasan está bueno pasará lo opuesto
vamos a mostrar lo que pasa en un
momento después de que los ventrículos
terminan de contraerse aquí tenemos un
punto donde podríamos tener un poco de
flujo en esta dirección y en esta otra
justo como lo dibujamos hace rato y por
lo tanto estas válvulas también se
cerrarán de golpe si se cierran porque
no quieren que la sangre fluya en la
dirección equivocada
entonces generan un ruido por lo tanto
cuando escuchamos está se debe a que las
válvulas pulmonar y aórtica se cierran y
esto significa que las otras dos
válvulas se abren las válvulas
tricúspide y mitral se abre es más vamos
a actualizar nuestra imagen para
mostrarlo estas dos válvulas se aprenden
y de nuevo la sangre entra a los
ventrículos por esto tenemos este ritmo
agradable cada vez que estas válvulas se
abren y se cierran generan un ruido
podemos observar que ya regresamos al
punto de partida básicamente tenemos un
ciclo completo
ahora si nosotros nos fijamos en la
secuencia entre tumba y tal tenemos un
pequeño periodo de tiempo en silencio
así que observemos así es como se ve en
el tiempo esta es una pequeña línea de
tiempo por aquí escuchamos atún o al
primer ruido cardíaco es decir ese uno y
por acá
escuchamos a ese 2 al segundo ruido
cardíaco después tenemos otra vez s1 y
s2 ahora bien lo que pasa entre s1 y s2
es decir ese pequeño periodo de tiempo
es que la sangre se bombea a los
pulmones y al resto del cuerpo ya que
las válvulas pulmonar y aórtica están
abiertas
este es el momento que la sangre va
hacia el cuerpo y los pulmones ya ese
pequeño periodo de tiempo le llamamos
sístole
y lo que pasa entre está y el siguiente
atún es decir en este periodo de tiempo
de aquí es que las aurículas vuelven a
llenar con sangre a los ventrículos y a
eso le llamamos diástole
ahora podemos escuchar a nuestro corazón
ya podemos encontrar el periodo de
tiempo entre tú y está y determinar que
en ese momento tenemos una sístole y si
esperamos el sonido entre tú y tú el
nuevo inicio del sonido entonces en ese
periodo tenemos una de ashton